welcome back to CBS this morning I'm Gil
King with Anthony Mason and Tony to
copal for the first time Facebook CEO
and co-founder that's Mark Zuckerberg
and his wife Priscilla Chan are sitting
down together for a network TV interview
we recently visited a couple at home and
at the office of the offices of their
philanthropic company the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative known as czi which
is four years old this week the same age
as their daughter there's a reason for
that well tell you all about the
ambitious work they're doing at the
initiative in tomorrow's broadcast but
first we spoke with them about the
couple's about the challenges that
confronting Facebook right now including
the criticism over its handling of
political advertising the main thing now
that people are talking about is the
political ads that you don't want to
take down political ads that people know
or false that they contain false
information what I believe is that in a
democracy it's really important that
people can see for themselves what
politicians are saying so that they can
make their own judgments and you know I
don't think that a private company
should be censoring politicians or news
but a small group of your employees
about 200 wrote a letter saying that
they wish that you would reconsider
because they said free speech and paid
speech are not the same do they have a
point well this is a clearly a very
complex issue and a lot of people have
have a lot of different opinions at the
end of the day I just think that in a
democracy people should be able to see
for themselves what politicians are
saying even if the ads are containing
false information that's I think they
should be able to judge for themselves
the character of politicians you were in
DC recently there it was reported later
that you had dinner with the president
of the White House what was the nature
of the meeting can you say sure I mean
we talked about a number of things that
were they were on his mind and I mean
some of the topics that you've read
about in the news around around artwork
the dinner was not disclosed by the
White House and only became public after
the fact through news reports it came as
President Trump was openly discouraging
Facebook from banning political ads
listen people would say the optics
weren't good did he try to lobby you in
any way
no I mean I don't think that that's that
I think some of the stuff that people
talk about or think gets discussed and
these discussions are not really how
okay how that works I also want to
respect that it was a private dinner
Brennan's proper discussion at the same
time Facebook faces antitrust
investigations into its dominance of the
social media marketplace at least two
federal agencies and 47 US states and
territories are asking if the company
engages in anti-competitive behavior
there's no question that there were real
issues that that we need to keep on
working on it but I think it's important
to not lose track of just the enormous
good that can be done by bringing people
together and building community people
who knows uh Coburg well say Facebook
wouldn't be the company it is today
without the influence of his wife
Priscilla Chan she's a teacher and a
doctor what mark and I talk about these
issues together is like I also have the
lens of being an educator and
pediatrician that's worked deeply with
families and individuals and all types
of communities and when i zoom out I
also see that these are societal
problems these are not problems that one
person one company can fix on their own
there's not going to be some silver
bullet but we need to work together as a
society for that steady progress she's
right you know they both believe that
these are societal problems it's
certainly keeping him up at night and
she's very concerned for him and how
they will navigate this forward but he
feels very strongly something is hitting
my mic he feels very strongly and how he
runs the company and he wants to do good
in the world and I think it's something
that they're all trying to navigate
there are societal problems but Facebook
is a huge role right now in terms of the
traffic of conversation around the world
and on these political ads it's
definitely a contrast when you hear our
colleagues at 60 minutes report just
last night that like you've been google
of taking out 300 political ads from the
Trump campaign Facebook apparently none
it's all new territory for a lot of
people everybody's trying to figure out
and do the right thing you can see more
of our interview with Mark Zuckerberg
and Priscilla Chan that's tomorrow on
CBS this morning including their goals
for the chance
Zuckerberg initiative will talk about
how they want to help listen to this
cure all diseases by the end of this
century they believe that it's possible
we're also the first-ever TV camera crew
that they allowed to visit their home
you'll see more of that tomorrow too
well it's a very happy home with two
very happy happy healthy children inside
the home it's great all right